dans leur jeunesse ils ont tous connu la
détresse une détresse handicapante les
coupant de la réalité aujourd'hui ils
peuvent mettre des mots sur ses
psychoses qui met à mal le lien social
j'ai été diagnostiquée on va dire
maniaco-dépressif appelé lady polaire
c'est c'est une maladie où on lit tout
le temps dans la tristesse il saura
faire des choses la niaque j'ai évolué
c'est pas ma famille c'était difficile
home agnostique eux ils me de ce groupe
d'élèves en même temps ça a changé des
choses qu'ils ouvrent généralement la
schizophrénie survient en cas de stress
de grande vulnérabilité ou de
traumatisme les patients sont en cassure
avec la réalité
cela se traduit par des idées délirantes
des hallucinations
la maladie peut affecter tous les canaux
sensorielle ils sont ultra stimuler en
période de crise qu'on trouve rue de
france commencé a dû apprendre tout ça
dans la rue après me disais oui c'est
quoi on trouvera une kitten ce que des
médicaments
asos de bain avec ma maman kim à city
chic
j'ai pu stabiliser ici dans cet hôpital
de jour
ils découvrent que leurs troupes ne
détermine pas leur vie et leur
personnalité
grâce à ses activités de stimulation
cognitive et d'habilité sociale ils
apprennent à prévenir la maladie et
reprendre confiance en l'avenir
l'un je me dis qu'on ne dit pas de
ciment c'est à deux pas d'ici là vous
déconnez pas malade pour unies abidjan
fou on est progrès ce soir j'ai pu
montrer si je suis à mme je trouve que
s'il ya une grande évolution que je me
sens limite la maladie loin derrière moi
mon rêve c'est de d'ouvrir un grand spa
en art il faut cibler les belles femmes
du theil le travail qu'on fait et qu'on
fait ici c'est une petite goutte dans
l'océan
le plus important se fait à l'extérieur
du centre de joe alex à l'extérieur des
structures hospitalières
ça se fait vraiment dans la cité dans la
vie écologique
alors c'est à dire le retour domicile
l'entourage le travail donc les
employeurs les amish et puis nous tous
nous tous citoyens
on ne guérit pas de la maladie en
revanche il faut généralement une
période de 8 mois en moyenne pour se
rétablir
80 % des patients ont une stabilité des
symptômes avec les traitements